a new wave of Russian strikes across
Ukraine whilst the death toll mounts in
the bloody battle for Batman but with
both sides seemingly as far apart as
ever is the warlocked in a violent
stalemate and what chances a diplomacy
this is Inside Story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
I'm Laura Kyle
a barrage of Russian airstrikes woke
people up right across Ukraine on
Thursday morning some of those
reportedly involved Hypersonic missiles
which can travel up to eight kilometers
a second is the latest wave of attacks
in a conflict that shows no sign of
ending Russia has a limited stock of the
advanced Hypersonic missiles which
Ukrainian defenses were unable to
intercept the change in tactics from
week to week has made the war hard to
predict and for those facing the strikes
they never know when a missile will come
to their home
I was in the park at 6am in the morning
on my way home a rocket flew over my
head it was very loud and after that
there were two powerful explosions I saw
that it was flying towards my house and
when I arrived I saw a big fire my car
was burning but there was nothing I
could do it was too dangerous it doesn't
make sense to me how this can be the
21st century there are some kind of wild
people for doing this just Savages
my house shook I immediately understood
that it hit somewhere next to my house
it is just 50 steps away I feel so sorry
for Aliana she was such a good girl and
more people died
well in the East I mean while Ukrainian
generals have promised to defend the
city of bakmud reversing speculation
that a pullout was imminent Moscow has
been pouring in military resources and
mercenaries from its Wagner group both
sides have suffered heavy losses the
capture of bakmut has become a major
military objective the city itself has
little strategic importance but the
lengthy battle suggests a symbolic
victory for whomever controls it
we'll get to our guests in just a moment
but first let's take a quick look at who
controls what in Ukraine Russian forces
have taken these regions in red and are
pushing a thin front line against dozens
of positions Ukrainian forces recently
took control of the city of Curson and
are resisting the Russian offensive
whilst awaiting much-needed NATO
equipment despite that concentration in
the East Russian Artillery and missile
attacks are still targeting other
regions across Ukraine
thank you
let's bring in our guests now and in
Moscow Pavel felgenhauer a defense and
Military analyst in Odessa Hannah
schlest director of Security Programs at
the think tank Ukrainian prison and in
bath England Patrick bury an associate
professor in security at the University
of bath a very warm welcome to each of
you Hannah let's go to you first because
these Russian missiles they've been
hitting cities and sites across Ukraine
including their in Odessa where you are
what happened where did they strike
you know the uh this attack was uh uh
one uh again for the critical
infrastructure the uh predominantly
energy infrastructure around the country
being targeted not so successful as
previously but we also need to
understand that this attack was the
first big attack after the months of
more or less calmness and smaller
missiles used against Ukraine plus they
used approximately 81 a different type
of missiles that's also demonstrates the
capacities of the Russian strikes as for
now because they use something like five
or six different types of the missiles
including six kinzhou and what is
interesting that that is a very rare
missiles Russians didn't have a lot of
them and the previous year they used the
same amount as they use during this life
so that demonstrates that each time for
such a big attack they are accumulating
efforts and accumulating those missiles
that they can use plus Iranian Shahid
drops again this night they produced
what was the point of these strikes
uh well officially it was announced in
Moscow that these were reprisals for an
alleged Ukrainian led a so-called
Parkinson raid in Brands Cobb West which
Russia described as a
terrorist attack and the Ukrainian
Authority says they didn't have anything
to do with it so this was some kind of
kind of reprisal mostly again targeting
Ukrainian uh power grid
infrastructure where apparently the
Russian very long already campaign of
such attacks were rather failed because
the power grid in Ukraine has managed to
continue and has the opinions have
managed to cover up their losses and the
power grid is functioning so in the
Strategic way it didn't work but
tactically yes it's a spectacular
attacks spectacular attacks Patrick do
do you agree with that what's the
strategy here as you see it from the
Russians using all these different types
of missiles including these Hypersonic
missiles
well of course the use of the
hypersonics and the different missile
systems is to try to get around and
increasingly uh capable air defense
Suite that Ukraine has
um and obviously we've seen them hitting
higher being able to Target higher
percentage of Russian missiles
um than they were saying the early
stages or steadily getting better
because the new systems are coming in
whether this is Japan or the Patriot
system etc etc and they're getting it
slowly but getting a layered air defense
system so using more advanced missiles
using um fired from different kinds of
platforms with different trajectories
just makes it more difficult to track
everything and take it down
um the strategy look I think the
reprisal thing is is definitely accurate
but I also think you know what we see is
a um a pattern here basically Russia
suffers a setback and then it unleashes
a series of barrage attacks and that's
been going on since last summer you
remember the attacks when they started
off on shopping centers Etc right
through to the then the concerted
campaign against critical National
infrastructure over the winter to try
and put the pressure on ukrainians
um and it's sort of amending to what it
would be uh comparable to a strategic
bombing campaign say in the second world
war the point is these these campaigns
don't work there's no evidence to
suggest apart from a local area at a
local level that the the populations
morale has changed for the worse you
know there's just there's no evidence to
suggest that why would you if you were
getting bombed then go oh yeah okay
let's give up it just doesn't work like
that you go no I want to kill them
Hannah I mean you are there do you agree
with with Patrick that this does nothing
to change the morale in the Ukraine we
must at the very least be absolutely
terrifying for people
uh definitely that is terrifying try to
spend your night in the shelter or with
the sounds trust me you would not like
it uh but the question is that we are
living with these for the whole year and
it is the psychology of people you use
to all the difficulties that you can
have that's one thing with this type of
attacks uh the situation is absolutely
the same uh first of all you cannot be
prepared for this you don't know which
region uh can be charged today we had
Odessa
so all around the country at the same
time uh really we were warned in the
beginning of the winter uh with all
these attacks against the critical
infrastructure because while it is
called
-10 minus 15 without electricity and
heating that's difficult but we survived
this winter uh both because we bought
all the general diesel generators other
types of the power Banks so all the
additional Supply that allowed the small
business and big companies to work and
house folks to work at the same time uh
spring came so definitely see that's
easier you're not afraid of being cold
for example and people just looked at
this and definitely becoming just more
angry but at the same time you know
anger is probably not the best term that
ukrainians feel against Russians
um and against these attacks discussed
that's something uh that all people are
discussing uh tiredness and disgust like
to the cucarachas you know when you're
coming to the old house they're coming
and coming and you're fighting and
fighting but you understand that one day
you are winning
Pavel these attacks just to stay with
them for one more moment these attacks
they did strike the zaparita nuclear
power plant and they've taken it offline
that is considered to be extremely
worrying by the rest of the World by the
iaea especially does Russia see that as
a victory uh well Victory would be that
if the ukrainians agreed to a kind of uh
if not a peace agreement the ceasefire
based on more or less the line of
control as it is right now accepting
Russian advances and Russian taking over
parts of Ukraine uh that's not happening
that was most likely the hope of this
whole campaign as it began to
deprive the ukrainians of power grid
during the winter it didn't work out as
it was intended because while these
missiles were quite a numbers Landing
but if compared to how many Americans
could send say cruise missiles well this
is not very much and most of the
missiles that are being used were
basically designed originally as a
Delivery Systems of nuclear weapons and
when they carry conventional ones well
they're not as effective just simply
they're not as accurate because they
when you're using nuke you don't really
need that much accuracy I mean any war
with NATO is where the Russian general
staff was planning a massive use of
nuclear weapons was envisaged and then
the number of the such attacks would
have been really deadly but then again
this is not a nuclear war this is a war
if not with NATO it's a war by proxy and
this thing is not working and Syria
usage missiles were also massively used
but they were kind of just an addition
mostly it was Russian bombers having a
hanging overhead and bombing here they
can't because Ukrainian air defenses are
too good for that and the Russian Air
Force is not good enough so this is not
really working strategically as it was
intended okay well let's Zone in then
level on the battlefield and look at
bakmud where perhaps one could argue
that Russia is having some more success
we've seen the Wagner group claim
control of the eastern part of the city
How likely is it Pavel do you think that
the group is going to take the whole
city in the coming days
uh well the Ukrainian command and
political leadership the parent who
decided to hang on in bakmud apparently
what's happening there right now on the
ground is that the ukrainians retreated
behind the line of the bahamutka river
which is a narrow but I would rather
steep Banks River they blew up several
Bridges and that it more or less divides
the city in half and that's a reasonable
position to take in the to continue
defensive action so that means taking
half is not doesn't mean they'll take
over very soon okay right now there's
something of a pause there as I
understand a pause but it has been a
battle of attrition hasn't it with huge
losses on both sides Hannah why is
zelenski refusing to pull forces out of
backwards even as it was reported it
does appear that his top military
commander suggested that they should
retreat
uh we have this news only in the foreign
media we don't have the confirmation
that the commanders asked uh to be
retrieved uh so that is let's say we
don't know what is the truth here but in
general we need to understand that
Russians are trying to uh um take the
city since July and that was very uh
important uh for drawing their forces
out meaning that they are losing a lot
of forces a lot of equipment and
ammunition there uh that is good for us
because they cannot advance and they are
losing there at the same time
strategically you're right this city
maybe is not so important but
psychologically that would be very
important for the Russian Federation
because they can prove that since July
they got at least some town and we need
to understand that bahmoud is quite a
small town 20 000 people it's uh like a
big Village in Ukraine uh it was a
symbolic City they are not important in
it historical and uh salt mines wherever
but not from the military point of view
but as the symbol as the symbol we call
it the Fortress back mode because of all
those fats happening from there those
battles that's why definitely uh the
forces astronaut was standing plus
that's allowed not to allow Russians to
go ahead because we understand that Mr
Putin announced his desire to occupy
completely the genetic region we already
heard several deadlines that he put for
his courses each time it's not happening
so it is ruining the Strategic uh plans
of the Russian Federation as well
Patrick what do you think about this
battle for bakmurt as Hannah points out
it's been going on for many many months
huge losses on both sides but it is much
more symbolic than strategic
seven months now yes I think so look uh
obviously political reasons Russia needs
a win and therefore this was the place
it was going to be
um uh and again it would have given them
more control of Donetsk and potentially
be under their control if there was a
negotiated settlement uh there's the
internal politics thing between gozin
and the uh the the Russian military and
he said he'll take it so he's got a lot
of interest to do so the Russian
military also came to undermine them and
take it themselves
um you've also got the because it's gone
on so long and sucked in so many people
and so many people have been killed
maybe 30 000 Russians
um you're going to be in the thousands
of ukrainians at least uh there's a
blood sacrifice there and when there's
blood Capital being expended there is
then political Capital which comes with
that yeah the Fortress back moves it
suddenly becomes a bit more important
than it was like Verdon in the first
world war you know in the Pastoral
Powers what the french said because they
lost so many people and unfortunately
it's a sort of reverse psychology that
doesn't mean you should kill more people
because you've lost so many people as I
know from serving in Afghanistan but
nevertheless
um I think really what's going on here
if you zoom out what this is about I
would view this as a shaping operation
by the ukrainians that means they're
trying to set the conditions using this
operation for other operations what are
they trying to do know that they've got
a defensive advantage in back route
they're at least killing um three times
amount of Russians for every one they
lose it could be up between five and
seven yeah and therefore it's in their
interests to continue this battle as
long as they can uh do so without
getting a lot of forces and circles are
cut off yeah
um what they're trying to do is drain
Russia and keep Russia attacking them at
a place of their choosing and that means
that Russia is not actually going on to
the defensive its focus is on taking
back mood and that makes a lot of sense
for Ukraine right now
so Papa what's your response to that
that in bakmut the idea or the thought
is the estimate is that three to five
Russians are being lost for every
Ukrainian are you hearing those sort of
numbers in Russia is that common
knowledge in Russia well it's very hard
to say because both sides are not
publishing their actual numbers of
casualties and who's losing more uh I
would assume that it's kind of more of a
sequel most likely like in the mentioned
birdover then in 1916 actually the
defending um French was more than the
attacking Germans uh but basically it
was more or less the same but they lost
a bit more but it's highly symbolic if
bakmud falls that's a great moral
booster for the Russians and for the
Kremlin and internal politics and
apparently military considerations are
taking second kind of place here for
both sides it's a a battle of wills like
Stalin grad like burden
uh a meat grinder actually and the
military considerations are secondary
how significant Pavel is it for the
Wagner boss you have guinea pregosian to
have this Victory he's becoming a very
powerful voice uh on the battlefield and
certainly is quick to criticize the
Kremlin and the defense Ministry if he
does not feel he's getting enough
support how significant is he becoming
well he says is kind of very significant
he has a private Army that has
dramatically expanded during the last
year from several thousand deployed
somewhere in Syria or in the Central
African Republic or I don't know where
to tens of thousands of Fighters with
his own tanks and artillery and he's
close personally to Vladimir Putin and
he's a publicly attacking the defense
minister and the defense Ministry his
second in command General guerrasimov so
he is a very vocal political figure in
Russia with his own private army
fighting out there and with Connections
in the Kremlin and he's financing it so
for him it's a very high uh importancy
thing to take over bahmoud and for the
defense Ministry Moscow Equity they
don't want him to take
Victory because he's their political
opponent so there's a lot of infighting
happening there on the Russian side
Patrick when you look at this infighting
happening between the Wagner group and
the defense Ministry do you see it
posing a problem for Russia in
presenting a united front against
Ukraine
I think that goes without saying you
know you don't want your a large
mercenary Army at odds with your army um
but listen Russia's had problems with
Commander control and Leadership since
day one of this war so
um it's par for the course at this stage
you know I think really you know the pro
the issue with Rebecca and they're like
where do they go if they take back moves
say they're full right so the land to
west of back moved directly west is that
a Higher Ground easier to defend the two
roads which lead Northwest and Southwest
the Northwest wants a Crematory you know
there'll be defensive lines around there
there'll be defensive lines around
chromatosk
um it it doesn't change the calculus
that much you know so far my view on
this again strategically this is about
reserves yeah it's about draining combat
power if Ukraine can get through this
you know grinding attritional Warfare
without committing the reserves which it
needs to keep back and intact for the
summer where it's going to try and
attack in probably one or two places uh
that's a victory for for Ukraine um
Russia is trying to take this in a meat
grinder effect it does have someone
committed reserves as far as we
understand but the chances of them being
able to conduct a a breakout and then
take vast ways of of Ukrainian territory
it's questionable to say the least so
it's really about Reserve Manpower and
an eye on the future of uh campaigns
coming in the Summers late spring okay I
just want to touch as well on the idea
of peace talks because they really don't
seem to be on the agenda at the moment
Hannah we've just had the UN Secretary
General Antonio guterres in Kiev no
mention of peace talks by him only
discussing grain and accessibility of
grain to the rest of the world is it on
anyone's Minds to get Russia and Ukraine
to the same table ah there are different
proposals coming just recently China
expressed their position the question is
the talks is just the instrument uh it
is not the ultimate goal the question is
what we are going to discuss at these
negotiations and here we see that the
Russian position has not changed since
March last year when we had these
negotiations at that time there were
much higher chances to find some
compromise or concessions from two sides
that to what we have up to the year of
those first Belarus and then Istanbul
negotiations that's why the United
Nations in General Secretary General
took very low profile uh during this
Invasion let's be honest and as for now
for him the grain deal is the most
important uh now this March it should be
yet one prolongation and we are not so
sure that Russia would allow this
prolongation that's why he is trying now
to negotiate this plus the nuclear
security that the Parisian nuclear power
plant that you talked earlier and uh in
general the nuclear security of all
Ukrainian nuclear power plants that's
also about what United Nations is
talking humanitarian Aid some stuff like
this but they are not ready to propose
anything more than least and looks like
the United Nations as Secretariat is
more waiting for others to propose their
ideas
where would those proposals come from
we've had something produced from China
the 12 point peace plan that's uh been
sort of dismissed quite widely as more
of a set of principles rather than a
plan what else where else could we get
ideas from
uh well the Russian Kremlin says that
they had the same proposals as last
March basically uh they would agree for
some kind of uh freezing of the
situation uh permanence is Fire based on
more or less the line of control
what some maybe negotiations here and
there kind of uh quit for a quid for pro
quo or something which Ukrainian is not
accepting and the West also is not
accepting at least present Western
governments though Donald Trump says
that he could achieve peace very swiftly
and most likely again on Russian terms
as said on uh ceasefire on the line more
or less on the line of control
so that means the positions of these
parties are miles apart
Russia also more or less though they
praised the Chinese proposal they said
that the recruitment said right now it's
not practical because there's no one to
negotiate with increa and TEF which
means that before there are decisive
action in the coming very late spring
summer military campaign which can
change the facts on the ground the facts
on the ground may change or may not
and already on the basis of that
somewhere in the summer beginning in the
Autumn there can be negotiations on a
finding something to kind of well
legalize the new situation on the ground
as it is by then okay so right now we're
looking forward for a big fight
Patrick I consume nodding that do you
envision peace talks by the end of this
year what will the situation on the
Battleground have to be like for that to
take place
I think pavel's exactly right though you
know that it's it's about fighting not
talking now and uh the results of that
will uh will inform any chance of
talking so there will be I'd imagine but
we know of opportunity come the old uh
winter but
um there's an interesting thing about
timing here you know as Pavel mentioned
Donald Trump's statement say who knows
if you'll be the president or not but
there is an election at the end of 2024
a very important one in the United
States of which United States policy
could change there is a section of the
Republicans that uh that said that the
U.S is essentially too involved in
Ukraine
um that will be weighing heavily on on
Ukrainian uh time scales I would have
thought secondly Russia if it holds on
you know it has an advantage of Manpower
an advantage in being able to produce
dumb weapons like artillery uh and over
time you know on the current trajectory
that may favor their their outcomes so I
think there's a there's a there's an
awareness essentially that Ukraine wants
to first of all do best it can this
summer and see where it is afterwards
and it doesn't really need to be your
want to be in a long-term battle you
know war with with Russia because it may
start to favor Russia again you've got
the whole point about Western commitment
to it which so far has been great in
terms of European commitment
um very strong but could that could that
waiver again it just the the variables
get a bit more um unknowable as the
longer Ukraine pushes this out so I
think there will be a window hopefully
in in in in the Autumn
um I wouldn't rule out unfortunately
depending on what happens on the
battlefield a frozen conflict through um
through escalation uh because we've seen
that happen previously for example in
Korea when nuclear powers are involved
so
um yeah I think um there's a lot
obviously to pay for and we don't have
full clarity of course
just the last four thought going to you
the longer this drags on as Patrick says
how concerned are you are ukrainians
about wavering Western support
we depend
s a living but but at the same time we
need to understand that it is not just
the United States with all big share
that the United States have now votes
politically and technically but we have
54 nations in the uh Ramstein group plus
the European Union just made a decision
about the joint uh of procurement and
production of the ammunition what is
really important for Ukraine so the
European Union and European cultures
would like to play bigger role in this
understanding that elections can change
the situation in the U.S that's why it's
just to me that we should not just speak
about the West as something United as
something single there are different
options and Ukraine is working on this
don't forget that Ukraine also produce a
lot of weapons by ourselves so it's all
that we are just relying on the supplies
from our Western Partners at the same
time Russian Federation is decreasing
the amount of what they produce it is
absolutely not the same level first of
all sanctions the second because uh
approximately 70 percent of the spare
parts of the emissiles are made abroad
but not in Russia and in Giants
Committee of their strategic missiles
used to be made in Ukraine so that's why
now we see much less production and they
are also in a hurry because of this they
understand that such attacks as this
Knight is not what they can do for uh
for a long time it's been a fascinating
discussion I want to thank all of you
for joining us here today Pablo
falgenhower Hannah schlester and Patrick
bury
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website that's
aljazeera.com and further discussion do
go to our Facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash AJ Inside
Story you can also join the conversation
on Twitter the handle is at AJ inside
story from me Laura Kyle and the whole
team here in Doha it's bye for now
[Music]